let's get more now on Hillary Clinton's
confirmation that she's running for the
US presidency litical commentator Irish
aramesh joins me now from Los Angeles
welcome to Sky News but what do you make
of the way that she announced her
candidacy with this video and the tweet
well her candidacy was inevitable but I
think they tried to be much smoother
this time that they were in 2007 in the
upcoming 2008 election if you remember
back that everybody thought that hillary
was going to be the inevitable
democratic candidate and given how
unpopular president bush was everybody
work was assuming that a democratic
candidate would become president but she
faced an insurgency what a sight to see
of Barack Obama a somewhat unknown
senator from Illinois ran a great
campaign ran great guns and the Hillary
machine to Clinton machine was
eventually defeated so I think this time
they're trying to make sure not to make
the same mistakes or being very careful
not to make Hillary sound like the heir
apparent to the democratic from and make
sure that she a is likable she
sympathizes and connects with the
average Democratic voter especially in
the base the democratic the left-wing
democratic progressive base in key
states Iowa New Hampshire and Nevada
that is very important because too many
people she seen as the ultimate
Washington insider and this time she
seems to be selling herself as
grandmother in chief she seemed to be
using her gender something she was
reluctant to do last time around
absolutely if you remember even last
time when she lost the when she lost
Iowa where she came in third after Obama
John Edwards and she came third in the
first round and the Iowa caucuses when
they went to New Hampshire it was the
first time anyone saw Hillary Clinton
get emotional she actually cried she
shed a few tears and that was the first
time people saw a much more emotional
much more personable that side of
Hillary Clinton so this time she is
trying again to position herself as this
person who is connectable was likable
who
sympathizes with the average oh she
doesn't just come from the beltway and
by that I mean he Washington DC Beltway
and she is someone who wants to she said
in her own tweets she be a champion for
these causes for women's causes for the
middle class for the average Joe but
nevertheless what we are facing is a
possible rerun of a Clinton Bush contest
for the presidency does that make
Americans uncomfortable first of all
we're we're a long long way from
determining who is going to be the
eventual Republican or Democratic
nominee especially in the Republican
race we're up to 22 people are potential
candidates three or four have officially
announced to run and Jeb Bush has a
mountain to climb to get that nomination
in his own party he's going to face
severe a lot of resistance from the
libertarian base and also from the more
right-wing conservative Tea Party and
also religious right wing base so I'm
not sure if this is going to be a
Clinton Bush race again and also again
let's not forget that the primary season
has barely started even senator or
sector of State Hillary Clinton is going
to face some challenge from the base
people like Elizabeth Warren senator
from Massachusetts very progressive she
might run Bernie Sanders had
self-described independent democratic
socialist of Vermont he might run and
then Governor Martin O'Malley of
Maryland he might run it again the
biggest thing the biggest name in the
biggest unknown is going to be vice
president joe biden so let's not make
any assumptions at all about who is
going to go in to be the eventual
democratic or a Republican nominee
especially in the Republican primary
which i think is going to be one of the
most interesting Republican primary
races and Republican primary debates in
generations but what one thing she has
when she has huge celebrity but one
thing she also has which no other nobody
will have will she'll be offering two
for the price of one Bill Clinton should
be able to tap into nostalgia for the
bill clinton era absolutely I'm you know
a lot of people people who like the
Clintons or who don't you know they have
fair share of concern and criticism at
the same time admiration for a potential
first a gentleman Bill Clinton or some
people who would like to call him first
do it Bill Clinton so we'll have to see
how that's going to work out but clearly
the Clinton camp and the Clinton machine
and the Clinton Clinton political group
and organization is one of the best in
the most savvy in this country and the
Clintons have shown that they are
extremely capable and politically savvy
operatives political operatives they got
beat by the Obama axelrod david puff
sort of campaign in 2008 but they've
learned from their mistakes they also
have the backing of President Obama he
was interviewed a couple nights ago he
said he thinks Hillary Clinton you know
would make a great president she was an
excellent outstanding sector of state
and he appreciated all her support
during his camping so I think you do get
that too for one thing but against some
Americans will be uncomfortable with
these sorts of legacy presidencies to
bushes and in case there's another Bush
Clinton campaign sort of a runoff a lot
of Americans some Republican some
Democrat and some independence maybe a
little uneasy with these sort of dynasty
presidencies exactly yeah Irish our mesh
thank you very much for your analysis
good to talk to you